blade Smith's I will be testing the
strength and durability of your Blade's
tip by attempting to drive it through
this steel plate armor
are you guys nervous
there
Alan you're up first
[Music]
Alan you still have a tip there
it's good news it is good news I'm
impressed with how thin this tip is and
uh you don't you don't have any issues
there so
well done thank you
Mike ready yes sir
I'm thinking please please you know
don't break don't break just go through
it you know
my my biggest concern was the blade
coming apart where you had to re-weld it
yeah but held up
good deal Clayton ready I am
[Music]
Clayton is like I didn't even hit it my
concern was that you used burrow
material for your handle and you burned
it through I've never seen that stay
together except for today all right well
done thank you
bladesmiths to see how sharp the edge of
your blade is I will attempt to cut
through all these apples with one slice
and you're up first
well Alan because of your edge geometry
being uneven it did want to lift up on
the cut
but it's a sharp blade all right
Mike you're up next
Mike there's a slight delamination that
sticks out a little bit right there
being uneven it did want to lift through
the cuts
but nonetheless a test is about the
sharpness of your blade and it cuts her
Peyton you're up next you ready I am
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right whoa
Clayton the edge geometry you have
definitely made it easy to wheel the
blade complemented by the handle it's a
good fit this blade definitely Cuts
thank you
blade Smiths the judges have made their
final decision
it's time for one of you to leave the
forge
Mike
your weapon did not make the cut
Mike first off I want to thank you for
showing that even when you have a
catastrophic blade failure
you can find ways to fix it but the time
it took for you to take care of those
problems wasn't applied to taking care
of those first round issues that
delamination that's why we got to let
you go thanks for the kind words
Mike please surrender your weapon
I try my best but I wasn't good enough
but that teaches you you know how to
survive there is a Russian saying
which means survive Against All Odds
which I did